pas clair qu'est le marc lavoine je ne
veux qu'elle alors publicly type des
clips gouren 6-1 et puis alors
maintenant vous allez faire un album
avec marc lavoine
j'ai déjà bien profiter du bonheur de ce
disque elle a un bon ailleurs continuer
à travailler avec lui si je devais faire
ma musique est ce que j'avais fait un
album j'aimerais beaucoup qu'ils soient
là pour moi parce que déjà c'est un ami
quand mon ami nous entendu bien ah ouais
là samedi rien ça fait quand même elle
qui m'a choisi c'est tara qui me choisir
regard d'un matelas tout le monde de
toute façon fait son marché ici un
claude berri nous a expliqué qu'il avait
vu les midis de kehl dans cette émission
aussi c'est pour ça que vous êtes là
parce que là il ya plein de réalisateurs
qui vont voir vous allez plein demande
encore si vous en aviez besoin
comment ça va vous à part ça depuis
votre séparation avec votre grand amour
ça très très bien je suis porté la
solitude mais vous êtes comme carrie
faire le fait de fait des émules à vue
c'est très bon ça faut pas toujours
avoir 24 heures sur 24
quelqu'un sur le dos oui on se dévalue
oui très bien seul
c'est vraiment content and vient ensuite
mordu personne un vrai supporter soit 24
a pas de problème vous cherchez quoi
comme type de tif quelqu'un qui me
bouleverse les genres grand petit jeu
par la sepa 60 kg 102 kg vous voulez
quoi comme je suis femme comme
destinations soleil le week-end prochain
week-end prochain comme destinations
soleil au soleil j'irai
fortement au soleil non gérard wissang
faut trouver un mec il a loué son abord
vous voulez quoi comme genre d'hôtel je
préfère aller louer une maison qui s'est
possiblement j'ai pas de problème mais
si bien sûr la maison à ouessant oui
comme champagne peut pas quoi comme marc
gêné nico nicolas feuillatte d'accord
pas de problème comme préliminaires
voulez quoi
bon j'arrête hockey